الان الى التطورات في الضفه الغربيه حيث
يتواصل التصعيد العسكري مراسل الجزيره في
رام الله قال ان قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اقتحمت قريه كفر اللبد شرق طولكرم وبلده
عقربه جنوب نابلس شمال الضفه الغربيه
واضاف مراسلون ان قوات الاحتلال تحاصر
منزل عائله الاسير اسامه بني فضل منفذ
هجوم حواره في شهر اغسطس الماضي التي ادت
الى مقتل مستوطنين
اثنين وننوه الى هذه العواجل اذ افاد
مراسل الجزيره عن ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تقتحم في هذه الاثناء بلدتي
صريف وبيت امر شمال مدينه الخليل وبلده
بني نعيم
شرقها معنا من الخليل مراسل الجزيره منتصر
نصار منتصر لو تضعنا في جديد ما يجري في
الضفه
الغربيه نعم هو يعني ما يجري في محافظه
الخليل جنوب الضفه الغربيه هو استمرار
للاقتحامات المستمره وال المتواصله منذ
السابع من اكتوبر لمناطق متفرقه سواء في
محافظه الخليل جنوب الضفه الغربيه وحتى في
بقيه المحافظات الفلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه في الخليل هذه الليله قوات
الاحتلال اقتحمت بلده صورف شمال الخليل
وداهمت البلده بعدد كبير من الجنود المشاه
وفتشت عدد من منازل المواطنين وصادرت
مركبات لمواطنين المشهد لم يختلف كثيرا في
بلده بتمر شمال الخليل البلده الملاصقه ل
صريف حيث اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال منطقه
الثغرى في البلده واجرت تفتيشات واسعه في
المكان رافقت القوات التي اقتحمت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه ومخابرات الاحتلال ايضا واجرت
تفتيشات واسعه في
تلك المنطقه وانسحبت منها قبل قليل في
بلده بني نعيم شرق الخليل قوات الاحتلال
اقتحمت البلده قبل قليل ايضا واندلعت
مواجهات ما بين الشبان وقوات الاحتلال
وسمعت اصوات اطلاق الرصاص الحي في بلده
بني نعيم التي لا يزال الاحتلال يقتح هذه
البلده حتى هذه اللحظه ويجري ايضا تفتيشات
ومداهمات واسعه لمنازل المواطنين في بلده
بتعوى جنوب الخليل في ساعه مبكره من هذه
الليله الى قوات الاحتلال اقتحمت البلده
رافقتها ونشات كبيره مخصصه
لحمل المركبات حيث ايضا صادرت عدد كبير من
مركبات المواطنين في بلده بيت عوه جنوب
الخليل وهذا كله ياتي ب التزامن ايضا مع
الاستمراريه والمواصله من قبل قوات
الاحتلال لاغلاق مداخل مدينه الخليل
المدخل الجنوبي والشمالي مغلق في المدينه
وعدد كبير من البلدات ايضا والمدن وال
مخيمات في محافظه الخليل لا تزال قوات
الاحتلال حتى هذه اللحظه تغلق مداخلها
بالبوابات الحديديه
وبالسواحل حملات اعتقال مستمره ومتواصله
دين وشير ايضا غنوه الى ان قوات الاحتلال
ايضا
هذه الليله او في ساعه في ساعات النهار من
ال الليله الماضيه اقتحمت بلده السموع
وعلى فترات طيله النهار يعني حوالي ثلاث
او اربع مرات اقتحمت بلده السموع جنوب
الخليل وايضا قامت بمصادره مركبات
المواطنين في بلده السموع ولا تزال حتى
هذه اللحظه تغلق مدخل البلده بالبوابه
الحديديه منذ السابع من اكتوبر والسموع من
البلدات التي تشهد في العشر الايام
الاخيره اقتحامات مستمره ومتواصله ليلا
ونهارا كذلك ننوه وفق ما افاد به مراسل
الجزيره تحدث عن اندلاع مواجهات بين شبان
فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال في بلده عقربه
جنوب نابلس بالضفه الغربيه وهنا اسالك عن
هذه المواجهات التي تتخلل عمليات الاقتحام
التي تقوم بها الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وقوات
الاحتلال نعم يعني عندما تقتحم قوات
الاحتلال البلدات والمدن الفلسطينيه في
الضفه الغربيه يقوم الشبان الفلسطينيين
بالقاء الحجاره باتجاه قوات الاحتلال التي
تداهم البلدات والمدن الفلسطينيه منذ
السابع من اكتوبر غنوه الفلسطينيون في
الضفه الغربيه لا يعيشون بمعزل عم يجري في
قطاع غزه من تطورات مهمه وتلاحقه وبالتالي
الناس بات ليلها ونهارها واحدا الحقيقه
حيث ان الناس تبقى على المتابعه في متابعه
الاخبار وبالتالي عندما تقتحم قوات
الاحتلال المدن والبلدات
الفلسطينيه كما ذكرنا تندلع المواجهات بين
الشبان وقوات الاحتلال اضافه الى ان قوات
الاحتلال في الضفه الغربيه تحديدا ومنذ
السابع من اكتوبر اختلفت السياسه او
الطريقه التي تتعامل بها قوات الاحتلال مع
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه حيث باتت
تطلق الرصاص الحي بشكل مباشر باتجاه
الفلسطينيين لمجرد الاشتباه فقط وهنالك
عدد كبير من الشهداء الذين استشهدوا في
الضفه الغربيه منذ السابع من اكتوبر لم
يكن هنالك اي اطلاق نار او مواجهات في
المنطقه التي استشهد فيها عدد كبير كما
ذكرنا من الشهداء لكن الاحتلال لمجرد
الاشتباه يطلق النار ويطلق الرصاص الحي لم
يستخدم الاحتلال منذ السابع من اكتوبر
الرصاص المطاط فقط يستخدم الرصاص الحي
ويصيب الفلسطينيين في مقتل وهذا يفسر
العدد الكبير والمرتفع من الشهداء الذين
استشهدوا ما بعد السابع من اكتوبر حوالي
300 شهيد ارتقوا ما بعد السابع من اكتوبر
ونتحدث عن عدد مرتفع ايضا مقارنه بالسنوات
الماضيه منذ بدايه هذا العام ايضا فاق عدد
الشهداء في الضفه الغربيه ال 400 شهيد
وهذا كله يدلل ويشير على ان الاحداث
والتطورات مستمره ومتصاعد في الضفه
الغربيه سواء على صعيد المواجهات التي
تندلع بين الشبان وقوات الاحتلال او حتى
على صعيد حملات الاعتقالات المستمره
والمتواصل والتي فاق عدد المعتقلين في
الضفه الغربيه ما بعد السابع من اكتوبر
حوالي 4000 معتقل وهذا عدد كبير ايضا
مقارنه باوقات ماضيه من الاعوام الماضيه
وهذا العام بالتحديد او حتى سياسه
الاغلاقات التي تفرضها قوات الاحتلال في
الضفه الغربيه اغلاق بالبوابات الحديديه
والسواتر الترابيه لكل محافظات الضفه
الغربيه بات المواطنون في الضفه الغربيه
يعانون كثيرا في موضوع التنقل بين المدن
والبلدات الفلسطينيه في الخليل على سبيل
مثال نعمو دهنا الوقت شكرا لك من الخليل
مراسل الجزيره منتصر
نصار